if someone who spent decades of their
life and they compress it into a book
and you can read it in an hour or a few
days you have such an advantage
most people feed their minds with
garbage and that's why most people don't
like their life take some time and
really look at who you're surrounding
yourself with rise and shine it's
expresso time what's up believe nation
it's up in my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have an
amazing gift inside you that I want to
see exploded onto the world so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
feed your mind with greatness over to
you Tony Robbins so what do you think
was the first real breakthrough that you
had as a team that started you on your
path and how did you get there just so
many other one of the first ones I think
was probably just anchoring in when my
mom and my dad i ported father's my mom
was a powerful woman so she kicked my
fourth father out whose name I carry and
he adopted me and when he went out she
decided to listen his side so she kicked
me out too by chasing out with a knife
and I wasn't worried she's gonna stab me
or anything but I decided this is
freedom and I've got to find a way to
make my life work but I had no money out
of 1960 Volkswagen I worked 40 dollars a
week as a janitor to buy and pay for and
so I had no car and no money I don't
know anything
I went slept in a person's laundry room
and then I decided I've gotta figure out
what to do with I needed a feed my mind
because I was so depressed I was so
overwhelmed I'm missing my brother and
sister and feeling just completely out
of sorts so I I got on a bus and I
traveled 14 miles a number because I
ended up running at one time and I went
to this book store and I bought this
book called the magic of believing my
quad head crystals the first real book
other than maybe thinking go rich or
Emerson's essays and I started on this
journey of saying every single day I'm
gonna feed
my mind I'm not going to hope good
thoughts show up
I'm gonna read biographies I'm gonna I'm
gonna find out what makes people tick
I'm gonna understand what makes me tick
and I I wanted to read a book a day but
I didn't do that click to the speed
reading class and I read 700 bucks over
seven years and they're all personal
development human development psychology
physiology and then what I try to do is
take anything that I learned and apply
it and then when I applied it you know I
was 5-1 in my sophomore in high school
I'm six seven now I thought people
differences personal growth but
sincerely I I became mister solution
because I wanted to help everybody so I
was this little fact about and I
couldn't lose weight and I lost weight
all my buddies are like how'd you do
that I said well here's what I did they
lost weight man we all got girls and as
a young kid given that led to where you
know if you have problem I was mister
solution specially if your girl has
motivated energy so if the breakthrough
was really understanding the power of
compressing decades in the days and if
someone has spent decades of their life
and they compress it into a book and you
can read it in an hour or a few days you
have such an advantage because when you
learn by your own experience it's
painful and it's slow when you learn
about other people's experience
everybody knows in the financial world
other people's money is leveraged right
well other people's experience is more
powerful in other people's mind because
you can have the money and lose it but
if you get the experience you can change
it all so I think that was the beginning
for me and it set me on a wife long path
of hunger and I never lost my hunger
most people feed their minds with
garbage and that's why most people don't
like their life when you have a problem
in your life whether it's in your
business or relationship whatever
problems come up you have two options
option one is you fix the problem as you
learn is you get better is you educate
yourself is you you improve yourself to
try to tackle that problem head-on you
see the problem and you run directly
into it option two is you run away from
it you escape you pretend like it
doesn't exist
you run away you hope that it goes away
on its own it never will and that's
where most people live
most people don't tackle problems
head-on most people don't accept
accountability responsibility try to
improve try to get better try to learn
most people they want to escape
do you want to complain they want to
blame they want to run away they don't
want to have to deal with that problem
and that's why most people's lives
they're not happy with it if you're
happy with your life great but most
people aren't most people are not happy
with where they are on and it's because
they spend most of the time escaping
instead of learning and improving and
fixing look at content look at YouTube
channels look at movies look at look at
the YouTube channels that you subscribe
to look at most of the content that gets
created it falls into two buckets the
first bucket is educational the first
bucket is how to the first bucket is I'm
gonna feed my mind with greatness I'm
going to feed my mind with a skill or
our new tool set that's gonna help me
get to where I want to go and the second
bucket is escapism the second bucket is
is comedy is jokes is laughter is making
fun of somebody and what are the
trending videos go to the top trending
videos on YouTube right now it's gonna
be mostly the second category it's the
escapism it's the I want to lock away my
brain and shut off the rest of the world
and just pretend like I can laugh at
somebody else's problems that I've deal
with my own that's what most people do
instead of fixing their problems most
people come back home from work and then
they spend an hour or two or five binge
watching comedy and jokes and
entertainment so that they don't deal
with their own problem and now there's
nothing wrong with a good comedy movie
there's nothing wrong with with laughing
there's nothing wrong with entertainment
but if that's where you're spending most
your time instead of actually fixing the
problems that you have and getting
better and growing and learning you're
never gonna get the left you want period
it's why most people are looking forward
to the weekend and most people looking
forward to that vacation that's coming
up you're escaping instead of running
towards the problem and fixing the
problems that you have and actually
building a better life for yourself
you're escaping and you can't wait for
that vacation in that weekend to come
and so I encourage you to audit your own
YouTube history your own information
content go look at your history look at
how many videos you're watching our
education are building you up are making
you better and how many are just funny
things that you're laughing at
pretending that the world doesn't
existence shutting out your problems
when you can fix that ratio where the
when you pay attention to the
information that's coming in here when
you feed your mind with greatness when
you create that environment that habit
that routine that everyday you are
feeding your mind with things that make
you better and help you tackle the
problems that you have in your life and
help you move towards the goals that you
want to accomplish when you do that on a
daily basis I promise you things will
get better it may be tough at the
beginning because you have to deal with
realities things that you don't want to
deal with problems that you don't want
to take on but every time you take on a
problem when you crush it and usually
the confidence to go do greater things
and build a better life for yourself
and for the people around you and so I
highly highly highly encourage you to
make that ratio right to feed your mind
with greatness every single day on a
consistent basis and if you did that I
promise you I promise you good things
will happen now I've got some really
special bonus cups you but before that
my question of the day what is a thing
that you do on a regular basis to feed
your mind with greatness leave it down
the comments below I want to see what
you have to say thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus clips
[Music]
the road to the bag is definitely tied
to your team and the company that you
keep
if you are surrounding yourself with
different energies that's not on the
same wavelength as you if they not
praying for you inspiring you supporting
you for showing you a better way hello
remove them immediately or you could
take them to church pray for taking the
church but you can't help them get there
oh you got to take care yourself you
know what it's called it's like we
talked about the other day is like being
on the airplane and the thing come down
you got to take care of yourself first
you know they put the mask on put the
mask on really take some time and really
look at who you're surrounding yourself
with look who's to the left and to the
right of you it ain't like minded are
they disciplined are they pushing you
forward it's so simple for us to solve
this a lot of the hardest problems are
so easy to solve we just have to take
those steps which are hard and be
mindful of that because trust me that
energy is gonna affect you if you're
around those and gangsters you gonna be
in jail if you're around casters talking
negative you gonna be negative if you're
around some brush you're gonna be rope
broke freeze Punk be around some month
if you're around God and some money you
on your way you're on your way you're on
your way I want to make some money I
can't make I can't really be successful
by myself
I need other people around me so you
where you are as great as your team I
mean any life is different and I try to
just remember that you know it's it's
really been the people surrounding me
growing up and and and my family members
and the Biddle's of my friends I kind of
formed Who I am so I do believe a lot of
that context and environment and
you know as a part of [ __ ] who you are
not only nature so you know I would want
to do that with you know with a family
one day two seconds I'm telling
everybody that I know everybody that I
have a few years younger because I did
have some amazing people like I am now
in their 20s who are great support to me
and who I was able to open up to and
even though it's really scary
to sometimes kind of reach out and ask
for somebody just to have a little chat
about anything it's normally like you I
truly yet still remember those people
could just open up their arms I'm like
of course let's just go out for a coffee
I mean come on I went through the same
thing and that is what you maybe have
the illusion of like I'm the only one
and it's usually never out of the case
you can do anything you can be anything
and yes obstacles will come along but
once again we are living in a whole new
world some people are making a living of
just making videos one of my favorite
youtubers jenna Marbles genius just a
short video every single week but she is
creating abundance what about Michelle
Phan right makeup she started way back
in the day but now she's created
something for herself and once again
there's there's always gonna be
obstacles right this ain't Paradise
Island out here right here in the jungle
in the jungle you don't know what to
expect there's all kinds of creatures so
you gotta ask yourself am i surrounding
myself with people that actually are
encouraging me to follow my vision and
my dream or am i surrounded myself with
what can you wear schools these are the
dream killers right raise your standard
Apple at the core is core values
and not one drop of myself work depends
on your it's suppose to mean I don't
ever give up I'd have to be dead or
completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten rose a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual Clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details